PARTY TO COMPLETELY DESTROY
ITSELF.
NO ONE EVER SAYS THAT BUT IT
MAY BE THE BIGGEST CHANGE HE
HAS BROUGHT TO THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S FASCINATING.
RADIO SHOW TAMMY BRUCE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
SHE HAS BEEN WATCHING
CAREFULLY.
>> UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Tucker: IT'S INTERESTING.
IF YOU ARE MAKING THE CASE
THAT TRUMP IS KIND OF OUT
THERE AND SAYS THINGS THAT
ARE ILL CONSIDERED AND IS HE
PROFANE.
THAT'S ALL KIND OF TRUE.
WOULDN'T YOUR RESPONSE BE
I'M THE RESPONSIBLE ONE.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE OUT
TRUMPING TRUMP BY LIKE XXX
AND THEY HAVE GONE SO CRAZY
THEY MAY NOT WIN THE HOUSE
BACK.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
>> LOOK, THESE WOMEN ARE
MAKING TRUMP AT THIS POINT
LOOK LIKE SIR GAL HAD WHEN
IT COMES TO HIS BEHAVIOR.
HIS THIRD AND FOURTH TERMS
AT THIS POINT HAVE BEEN
PRETTY MUCH SECURED AFTER
THESE DISPLAYS.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY TRUE.
>> THIS IS -- IT'S IN THE
NEW.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS BECAUSE
OF THEIR RAGE, THAT THE
CURTAIN HAS BEEN PULLED
BACK.
THEY JUST DON'T CARE ABOUT
HIDING THE NATURE OF WHO
THEY ARE.
YOU DIDN'T MENTION SALLY
FIELDS.
SALLY FIELDS THE ACTRESS,
THE FLYING NUN, ALSO
DEFENDED THE USE OF THE
C-WORD AND AT THE SAME TIME
WHAT SHE IS SAYING IS WHAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
NORMALIZE THE DEBASEMENT OF
WOMEN IN THE NAME OF BEING
ABLE TO ATTACK A WOMAN WITH
WHOM THEY DISAGREE BECAUSE
THEY THINK SHE IS
CONSERVATIVE BUT, OF COURSE,
THE IRONY IS IVANKA IS NOT A
CONSERVATIVE.
IT IS A MELTDOWN BUT IT IS A
REVEAL, ALSO, I THINK, WHY
SOMEONE LIKE WEINSTEIN COULD
SURVIVE SO LONG IN THAT
WORLD.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU ARE WILLING TO
REDUCE AND HAVE NO
PRINCIPLES WHEN YOU REFUSE
TO STAND UP FOR WHAT'S
RIGHT, BECAUSE SOMEONE IS A
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THAT ANYTHING GOES.
SO, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SEEING WHAT THIS MEANS.
THEY ARE SEEING THAT THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT A FRAMEWORK
NOT ONLY OF THEIR VALUES,
BUT OF A KIND OF AN
UGLINESS.
NOW, AT THE SAME TIME, LOOK,
PEOPLE IN MEDIA MAKE
MISTAKES.
ON THE FLY.
THAT WE KNOW THIS.
YOU GENUINELY CAN REGRET
SOMETHING AND APOLOGIZE.
THE PROBLEM WITH WHAT
SAMANTHA BEE DYNAMIC
REPRESENTS WHICH IS
DIFFERENT FROM ROSEANNE BARR
WHO IS DOING A TWEET, IT WAS
SCRIPTED.
IT WAS CLEARLY EDITED WITH
AN EDITING TEAM.
THEN IT WAS TAPED.
THEN IT AIRED.
THEN IT WAS PUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND IT WAS PROMOTED
AND WHEN THOSE VILE
MISOGYNISTIC WORDS HER
PRODUCER WAS EXCITED.
>> Tucker: SHE WORKS FOR THE
SAME NETWORK THAT OWNS CNN.
I HAVE WORKED IN NEWSROOMS
MY WHOLE LIFE.
I USE VULGARITY, I ENJOY IT
I DON'T WANT TO BE A BLUE
NOSE ABOUT IT THAT ONE WORD
THAT SHE USED I DON'T KNOW
ANY MAN WHO USES THAT WORD
BECAUSE IT IS THE ONE WORD
THAT IS ACTUALLY DEGRADING.
IT'S THE THING THAT
FEMINISTS ALWAYS TELLING US.
THAT WORD REALLY IS.
WHY THAT WORD?
>> IT IS FASCINATING.
IT REDUCES US TO A VILE
TERMINOLOGY, TO A PART OF
OUR BODY.
AND TO THE ULTIMATE
DEBASEMENT OF WHO WE ARE AS
WOMEN.
THIS HAS TRANSCENDS POLITICS
AND PARTY AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
THIS IS ABOUT LOATHING AND
HATE THEY HAVE NO IDEAS.
THEY SEE THE PRESIDENT IS
SUCCESSFUL.
WE SHOULD ALL BE HAPPY THAT
HE IS BECAUSE THE NATURE OF
WHAT HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
AND, YET, BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO COUNTER IT, IT
RETURNS INTO THIS, YOU KNOW,
ULTIMATELY, IT'S THE FRAUD
OF PEOPLE LIKE SNEIDERMAN OR
WEINSTEIN, THE NATURE OF
THIS KIND OF ATTACK, THE
MISOGYNY WAS MY FIRST BOOK
IN 2000 1, MISOGYNY AND
SEXISM, HOMOPHOBIA, RACISM
LIVES ON THE LEFT.
AGAIN, IT'S NOT ABOUT IF YOU
DON'T LIKE SOMETHING SOMEONE
HAS SAID, WE CAN ALL DEAL
WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> WE HAVE ALL MADE
MISTAKES.
THIS IS A CONCERTED,
SCRIPTED ATTITUDE AND THEN
FOR OTHER WOMEN TO SUPPORT
IT AND TRY TO NORMALIZE IT
SALLY FIELDS WAS WELL LIKED
TO SOME DEGREE TO TRY TO
NORMALIZE THIS DEBASEMENT
MEANS THEY, AT LEAST, HAVE
GONE OFF THE RAILS.
>> I GET THAT PEOPLE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, DISAGREEMENTS WITH
TRUMP.
BUT THESE PEOPLE ARE SCARY.
I MEAN, I DON'T THINK THEY
SHOULD BE ANYWHERE NEAR
POWER.
THEY ARE STARTING TO REALLY
SCARE ME.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT I